There's so many lesbian heroes that we don't talk about enough,
and this woman is one of them.
Meet Lorraine Hansbury,
a playwright and activist best known for her play A reason in the sun.
Lorraine was born in Chicago in 1930
and was the granddaughter of a freed
enslaved person. When she was 8 years old,
her family moved to a white neighborhood
where they faced violent attacks
and a court ruling that ordered them to move away
because they were black. Lorraine's family didn't back down.
Instead, they took the case to the Supreme Court and won.
Lorraine was heavily involved in activism throughout her life
and started her writing career at a progressive
black newspaper called freedom.
Later, she joined the daughters of Belitis,
the first lesbian,
civil and political rights organization in the United States,
and wrote about feminism and homophobia in their magazine.
She went on to write A Raisin in the sun,
a play about a struggling black family in Chicago.
It became the first play on Broadway
to be produced by an African American woman.
Sadly,
the rain passed away from pancreatic cancer at the young age of 34,
but her legacy lives on to this day.
A Raisin in the sun
is considered one of the best place in American history
and has made its way from Broadway to television and film.
Follow feminist for more feminist history stories like this.